Laura Ingram is the host of the Ingram
angle she joins us tonight Laura thanks
so much for coming on it's it's a little
weird to get these lectures every day
about how we have to drain the U.S
treasury and send it to some Thug in a
track suit in Ukraine because human
rights but China is throwing people in a
concentration camp so no one will say
one word including John Kirby who should
be ashamed of himself yeah all the
people that you mentioned Steve care of
course LeBron James silver uh Larry Fink
from BlackRock heads of Goldman Sachs
the Nike CEO the U.S media a lot of
Libertarians sadly and in the Republican
Party they're all complicit here let's
let's be very clear what's going on
China is a slave state there is no gray
area they are an evil dictatorship and
they seek world domination okay they
hate they hate the blue States the red
States and everything in between in the
United States the only people the that
are making billions of dollars in China
care about is is their own power their
own access and their own bottom line
there they'll sell out their mother for
a buck they'll sell out their mother for
power and apparently they'll sell out
their National interest so there are a
lot of people who are collaborators and
complicit here Tucker and yet they want
to hold up Russia Russia Russia as the
biggest threat in the world I'm not
saying it's not a threat it is a threat
but comparing China with the largest
standing army in the world to Russia
whose economy I believe is about the
size of France's is ridiculous and China
as we know is funding uh the war in
Ukraine right now
so I mean it's I'm so glad you're doing
this tonight because this is the single
biggest threat to freedom and our own
sovereignty Independence in the world
right now it is in China and our
Southern border so I could I'd be happy
to live in a country that sort of let
other countries do their thing and
they've got weird customs in Afghanistan
or Brunei or Saudi or even China
whatever and like they do their thing we
do ours I would be happy with that what
I'm bothered by is the same people who
are defending Mass concentration camps
and China are attacking America these
supposed Adam Silver
Eric swalwell Joe Biden it's all about
attacking America as immoral why can't
they just support their own country if
if they're not going to criticize China
why not support us well the binds have
made millions and millions of dollars in
China number one uh but number two these
these people loathe the American
tradition we we but they believe we're
an evil awful racist Nation with sins
that can never be redeemed and can never
be real reparations are not never going
to be enough so we can never do enough
to atone for our sins in their View and
and to your point about Kirby and what
he would not say today remember what Joe
Biden said on June 2nd 2020 after the
Floyd protest really exploded he said
they were very legitimate Grievances and
they should be a wake-up call for
America that's what he said when our
nations in many cases were erupting in
violence and in Flames yet their their
mute on a slave state in China and
they're the Civil Rights Crusaders
excuse is made they're all frauds
John Kirby is supposed to be an adult he
comes on Fox News he should resign his
job tonight he should be ashamed of
himself that he is a mouthpiece for this
grotesque policy and I hope that he has
enough dignity and self-respect to
resign and we need Republic and we also
need
who are fine finally speaking the truth
about this issue and are not beholden to
the investment banks on the multilateral
corporations that are continuing to fund
this military regime and dictatorship in
China we see what they're doing and it
is horrific I agree with that completely
Laura Ingram great to see you tonight
thank you good to see you Tucker thanks
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else